and rotate might be the most talked
about man in the world why I'm not
totally sure he's made a name for
himself giving advice to anyone and
everyone who will listen now Andrew Tate
has sat down for an interview with Piers
Morgan it has gone completely viral
millions and millions of views I have
not seen it yet but I'm going to watch
and see if I can be a guru to the guru
if I can give any sort of advice to
Andrew Tate on how this interview could
have gone better right now head on over
to bambi.com enter Michael Knowles under
podcast when you sign up when you're
running a business you run into all
sorts of interesting scenarios the
mandatory sexual harassment training the
wrongful termination suits an employee
not showing up to work on time one
complaint can destroy your entire
company now this problem is HR managers
are extremely expensive they can easily
cost over eighty thousand dollars per
year with Bambi you get access to your
own dedicated HR manager starting at
just 99 a month this is an incredible
service all of Bambi's HR managers are
based in the United States they can
support the nuances across all 50 states
your manager is available by phone email
and real-time chat to help you
effortlessly run employee onboardings
and terminations encourage good
performance make sure your business
stays compliant with those ever-changing
HR rules go to bambi.com right now type
in nulls under podcast when you sign up
that'll really help the show that's
b-a-m-b-e-e.com enter Michael Knowles
under podcast
I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but I've I've been
married twice as it turns out and on
both occasions I didn't believe that the
woman was being handed to me as chattel
regardless of what Andrew Tate is about
to say or even what was ever was in the
clip I do think he made a slight mistake
they're coming out of that clip he
immediately got defensive before Piers
Morgan ever asked him questions of
course what do you think what what where
that would seem to imply that something
he said was uh demanding of a defense
when if he really believes what was said
in the clip he would just sit there
quietly and sort of confidently and wait
for the question to be asked so already
I could see how this interview started
to go wrong because already he started
out from a position of Defending
and trying to explain a little and you
know if you're in that defensive
position you're already losing so would
you rephrase what you said there now
what that's that's an interesting point
about phrasing the way I would say
things before I was famous I have to
take personal responsibility and accept
right that if I make a video that 500
people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that five million people
see and one percent of them under so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's property she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has seen
it herself right so this is just not a
good argument If he if he's saying man
has a leadership role in the household
or even you know man is the head of
woman as Christ is the head of the
church or something like that that would
be one thing but to say that therefore
because she takes his name she's his
property that doesn't make sense this is
this leftisters tumbler is my property
it's not you know the leftist tears
Tumblr Knowles it's just a complete
non-sequitur I think the argument he's
making is a wrong one to begin with
which is why appears Morgan is attacking
him but he's not doing a very good job
defending it listen my friend if you
want to argue about this you need to go
back to the Bible to the Quran you need
to argue with religious talk about
anything in the Bible of Quran that's
what it says no no I'm asking you what
you think I think that if a woman
marries a man and she decides to take
his last name that they have different
roles and responsibilities within that
marriage and I believe that that's not
the question true she's had I believe
like a politician the father hands her
to the man Robert don't be a politician
because I think you're a straight talker
right you keep telling me you're
straight talk I think my sister is her
husband's property do you regret saying
it like that I understand that with my
newfound Fame perhaps it could be
phrased differently however I still
believe that a woman is given to the man
in America he's in a tough position
because it's just it's just a false
statement it just isn't true I'm pretty
Trad you know I totally love uh gender
roles and I believe in marriage as
marriage is traditionally understood and
I I'm on board with all of that but it
just is not the case that the wife is
the property of the husband to be
considered like all of the husband's
other property that is not a Christian
understanding of marriage and that is
not the traditional understanding of
marriage within our own culture so it's
an indefensible position I don't know if
Tate believes it or not he keeps saying
well I would have you know maybe you
know I offended some people or they
misunderstood it or whatever but it's
just it's just a losing Point either he
could change his opinion or he could
just move on but there's no way that
he's going to win by doubling down on
something that just isn't isn't true
yeah but not as property now the
property is the word that other people
use
that's what marriage actually means he's
showing you here why he is losing to
peers In This Moment he's he's ex when
he's trying to explain what happened in
these previous interviews he goes yeah
but property that's not my word that's
the word that was used in the questions
right and it's your responsibility when
you're conveying your arguments to not
just take the bait and all the kind of
leading silly premises of the questions
that you're asked you might be asked
some dumb question hey Andrew Tate when
was the last time you beat your wife to
use a classic example you don't need to
say uh uh uh well what you know that
that's a that's a silly premise that
sets you up to lose you should reject
the premise and say what are you talking
about property I think
man has a leadership role in the
household that would be controversial
enough
but if you if you take the bait on the
question you're boxing yourself into a
corner and now he doesn't know how to
get out of it you can't blame people for
asking you questions surely if you want
to be accountable for what you said
you've got to own your responses don't
blame the question I own the response
let me ask you a question no and you say
something and then say well I shall
blame you for I understand Pearson peers
I understand I believe the woman is
given to the man I believe she's given
away by the father I believe she belongs
to the man
that a woman becomes a man's property I
believe she belongs to the man in
marriage correct right
that to me is misogyny and you're
entitled to your opinion right but do
you want do you not understand why
people think it is misogyny I understand
why some people can be very offended by
what I say what they do is they take a
point like that and they ignore all the
other points I make the other way right
but that's why that's why I've
repeatedly asked you about that line to
see if you've changed your position but
the reality is you haven't it's not
about changing positions I'm a
full-grown adult and I stick by the
things I say in reality is he has which
is which by the way is fine absolutely
so we can tell that's why he's trying to
get out of this little exchange you said
you know I wouldn't maybe say things the
same way now that I did before I was
famous and yet actually you've doubled
done it's exactly the same thing on
certain points so that is what you
believe that's my point yes I'm trying
to work out look I don't know you we
just met right yeah I'm trying to work
out who Andrew Tate is and what you
actually believe I don't want to twist
anything at all then maybe make it very
very clear to the camera I believe a
woman is given to the man in marriage I
believe that I also believe a man has a
duty to protect and provide for her he's
obviously saying that a woman is not
property right to say a woman is given
to a man in marriage and that a woman
that the wife belongs to the husband in
a very deep sense that's very different
than saying the woman Belongs To The Man
in the way that the leftist tears
tumbler belongs to me as property and to
say that the man has a responsibility
toward the woman to protect the woman
that's very different than saying the
woman is property I don't have a
responsibility to protect my leftist
tears Tumblr I could throw it against a
wall and go buy a new one man can't do
the same thing for his wife or at least
he certainly shouldn't do that so and
what Piers wants to do here is also sort
of dishonest because he keeps trying to
say that's still your opinion that's
still your opinion but if you're
listening to what Andrew Tate is saying
he's clearly saying that is not my
opinion the implication I think is I
said a dumb completely indefensible
thing but I don't want to admit that I
said a dumb indefensible thing so I'm
trying to both defend my view I'm trying
to say I stand by my views but then
change the view in what I'm explaining
and it's just
difficult to listen to if something
happens or his wife's life is threatened
I believe that Women and Children First
are on the light boat lifeboats but I
believe that men but a man doesn't own a
woman it's not no it's honestly
literally buy them as a slave well
obviously we're not talking about that
we're talking about religious biblical
marriage we're talking about something
else yeah but I'm a Christian I don't
believe that I I I I own my wife do you
believe your wife was given away to you
when she took her last name I believe
that there is a process where a father
traditionally walks his daughter down
the aisle and hands his daughter to this
man and they stand there and become a
union of two loving people in a
partnership no because there's no
ownership involved I didn't say he's not
selling her the Father of the Bride
isn't selling his daughter no absolutely
means he becomes a member of your family
I think we're arguing over semantics
we're not there because fundamentally I
don't believe you are but semantics
means meaning so yes we are always our
semantics but I don't think we live in
the world of slavery I don't own any man
or any woman right nobody owns it when
you use phrases like property that's
what you apply and so my point again is
you're a smart guy right there's no
denying that you're a smart you're a
good talker I've seen a lot of the stuff
what I don't think you quite fully
understand no I understand when young
impressionable people I understand you
are not as smart see things like I think
my sister is a husband's property yes
and you've just reaffirmed that that
belief they think that they have the
right to own women I understand that
very well Pierce which that's why people
think you're a misogynist completely I
understand all of this very well which
is why when you're saying I was
backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret though over the way you phrase
this stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds could be taken out of
context that was not my anticipation but
it's not what you believed it's what you
believe now so what's the difference
it's manifestly not what he believes you
just listen to what he's saying he said
to me look look there's honestly I've
had time to think about it he just
doesn't want to admit he's wrong said it
I don't believe that that's one thing
actually you've said the opposite you
said actually that's what I think yeah I
think that when uh so it doesn't really
matter whether you recorded it when you
famous or not famous it's what you
actually believe right I believe that a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for a woman I believe that uh a woman's
father gives her away to the man that's
what I believe and that's in in my
marriage that's that's the circumstance
I'm going to live under if people want
to live in a different scenario that's
completely theirs they're prerogative
you went on to say about authority over
women if I have a responsibility of it I
must have a degree of authority yeah for
the same reason if I have responsibility
over and people are going to use their
mind it's an example an energy
responsibility over a child I have to
have some Authority so you believe as
part of your ownership or your property
of of the woman you have authority over
her no I believe if you ever that's what
you said I believe you've ever
responsibility over something you have
to have a degree of authority you can't
be responsible
again you're the boss the point I'm
making yeah if you're playing this point
the point I was trying to make was
talking about the safety of a woman so
now now Andrew Tate
he's almost it's almost the opposite
problem in the first part the first part
when he says the woman is the man's
property that's just silly and it's not
true and he shouldn't defend it and if
he doesn't want to come off as weak and
like he's backtracking then he should
just try to move on and say yeah
whatever here's what I believe you asked
me what I believe here's what I believe
dude probably I just told you what I
believe and just move on now he gets to
the question of does does a husband have
authority a certain kind of authority in
the household duh is the is the husband
in a certain sense the boss of the
marriage duh
so here he should just completely double
down but he's so been off-footed and
Piers Morgan is very good at this at
off-fitting people at the very top of
the interview he's soaping off footage
he goes well no actually that's not
exactly what I mean but you should just
double down be like yep absolutely yeah
a husband has a particular Authority in
a marriage so you're
uh yes ultimately I mean it's not a
tyranny one hopes one hopes that it's
actually the union of two people into
one flesh you know but uh yes ultimately
the man has a leadership role in the
marriage duh deal with it peers he was
too uh strident and and obstinate in the
first answer and I fear he's not
obstinate enough in the second answer
just stand up for you said something
that's perfectly fine stick by it and I
was saying well I wouldn't let my woman
walk alone at night and they said well
you're not in charge of her you don't
get to decide what she does I understand
but if I'm responsible for her safety
and I'm the person who's burdened with
making sure she is safe I have to have
the authority to say don't put yourself
in unsafe situations the two things are
linked well you know you're an authority
you have the you could absolutely have
the right to say to the woman you're
with I don't think you should but
ultimately if she decides that I can't
force her right so Authority implies
that you have the ability yes you can
you're her husband you can say don't go
down dark alleys at night you can you
have the right to say that it's actually
two liberals arguing with one another on
these total liberal grounds of just
individuals with no ties of loyalty or
obligation to one another just freely
choosing whatever the hell they want and
Andrew Tate is as guilty of that silly
premise as as Piers Morgan is but no if
you enter into a marriage you surrender
some of your individualism and your
autonomy the man surrenders some of his
the woman surrenders some of hers and
the man absolutely has the right and as
far as I'm concerned the obligation to
say hey wife of mine even if you want to
go down a dangerous dark alleyway at
night and and put your life at risk I'm
not going to let you do that and I don't
really care what your individual
autonomy says I as your husband I'm
telling you don't put yourself in that
very dangerous situation he's got to be
a little more authoritarian it's gonna
be a little a little more conservative
than uh they tell me this guy's the most
right-wing guy on the planet that's not
a that's a very liberal answer that he's
giving if you think I'm gonna lock
somebody up in their room if that's is
that what you're implying no I just
think I don't think you know Authority
means I know what it means I'm saying
that if I use this is a different
description of what Authority if I have
responsibility for her safety then I
have to have the authority to tell her
not to do unsafe but Authority means
that you have some form of control over
this woman I I think you're trying to
I'm only trying to get to what you think
honestly I am I come with No Agenda here
at all I understand and I'm explaining
very very clearly if I have
responsibility over said subject I have
to have authority of it so let me say
you have children right right you have
responsibility for them I have I have
legal authority over my children that is
very different having legal authority
over my wife or my female part
completely but the point I'm trying to
make so you accept that but you no if
you're in a marriage you have a legal
Authority analogy of responsibility
certainly a sacramental friend these are
these are very these are actually really
important things they're important
things but you introduce you introduce
you interrupt me every five seconds so
it's hard for me to actually explain my
point the point I'm making he does very
simple you have children and you're
responsible for their safety so you're
going to have authority to say don't go
out at night perhaps because you want
them to be safe you have legal Authority
you have a legal Authority yeah legal
Authority I'm saying that if I had a
woman and the question where you've
raised this sound bite from I was asked
about protecting a woman making sure
she's safe and I would say I wouldn't
want her to go out at night on her own
because I'm responsible for her safety
and someone said well you don't have
authority over it to do that and I said
well no I can't force her to stay inside
but if she were to ask me how do I
protect myself at night I would say well
you should stay inside that's how you
should do that's I don't have an issue
with so we agree no it's just amazing
they do agree unfortunately and they're
both wrong on this topic you quite get
why there's a fury over what you say
with respect because the semantics point
would be we're saying the same thing in
different ways but we're not I'm saying
to you what do you say I have to have
some authority over a woman I say to you
you have no right to any authority over
a woman you do it because you're a
liberal purist and you don't you don't
recognize the obligations that men have
to women and women have guardian or
authority unfortunately Tate seems to be
agreeing legally appointed absolutely
not I agree however
when it comes to things like personal
response to your personal safety men
largely by Society are accepted we're
the protectors and providers we can sit
here and pretend that in the world we
live in if me and my wife were walking
down the street and men were to come up
and try and attack us I wouldn't be the
one fighting but we both know in reality
I would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
survive a degree of responsibility to
protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never put herself
and you have the authority to do it
stick with your first point man she
would come to me and say how do how can
I make sure
I don't interrupt you I just want to
point out that's not what Authority
means if someone gives appearance is
Right voluntary Authority is not
authoritic no but that's the point peers
is totally right here he's not right
about his his view of marriage and what
a big liby is but he is right but
Authority has a meaning and Andrew Tate
is trying to run away from that meeting
because he doesn't want to sound like an
authoritarian which is considered the
absolute worst thing you could be these
days his point was correct in the first
place yes
a husband has a certain authority over
his wife full stop end of story there it
is that's not absolute it does it is not
permitted to exceed the bounds of right
reason and the moral order and and be
arbitrary and capricious but a man a
husband has a certain authority over his
wife yes that's part of marriage just
you had it you were right in the first
place
say that to peers and move on a woman
comes to me and says I want you to keep
me safe she is handing me Authority for
her safety but do you understand the
difference between having authority over
somebody and somebody giving you
permission to have authority completely
I never said one is consensual and one
isn't but why are we pretending I do but
marriage is that consent too the
authority of the husband I have to have
some Authority and the point only if I'm
responsible for her safety if I'm not
responsible for a single position that
was sad that was sad because he just he
he made the opposite errors in the first
bit he tried to defend a stupid point
that that genuinely is I don't like to
throw around the word misogynistic but
it's as close to misogynistic as it gets
and it's just dumb and it's it it's
and not a good point the point that he
was trying to substitute into its place
actually was a good point that the
husband belongs to the wife and the wife
belongs to the husband and this looks a
certain way and and they have particular
roles yeah of course but he should have
just ditched that first point the peers
wanted him to defend and stood by the
thing he was actually explaining the
clip in the second one he should have
stood by the point he originally made
and not gone on to his explanation which
basically just tried to explain away
Authority as the voluntary Association
of two individuals which was a dumb
Point instead of going from here to here
to here he should have just been right
right down the middle should have been
right down to the bullseye the whole
time head on over to puretalk.com enter
code Knowles with the midterms coming up
here is something that you ought to keep
in mind every dollar that you spend is a
vote and you are casting those votes
again and again and again for companies
that are working hard to undermine
everything you believe in for instance
Verizon Wireless customers you are
supporting a company that canceled one
America news for their support of Donald
Trump ATT customers your wireless
provider doesn't just support the far
left CNN they own it T-Mobile customers
your CEO openly advised Democrats on how
to beat Trump in the 2020 election don't
give your money to woke wireless
companies stop it give it to pure talk
instead pure talk not only believes in
conservative American Family Values but
they also give you the best service at a
low cost unlimited talk text and plenty
of data for just thirty dollars a month
the average family saves almost one
thousand dollars per year that's a
thousand fewer votes for those cell
companies that want to keep you from
speaking freely I absolutely love it
incredible incredible service I have and
use pure talk now is your chance to show
Corporate America you are done funding
their leftist ideologies go to
puretalk.com and enter code at Knowles
save 50 off your first month incredible
deal on an already incredible deal go to
puretalk.com promo code Knowles for 50
off your first month
do you respect women absolutely why
wouldn't I do you think the 18 19 year
old woman are more attractive than 25
year old woman I think there's
Attractive people uh that's that's a
loaded question I don't know it's not
really is it I I can't know why I'm
asking you of course I do but I can't
sit here and so the benefit of you is
you don't know why I'm asking you said
this in general this is also one of the
reasons men find youth attractive you
want to block the internet or block the
internet right effing now the reason 18
and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less
people say oh you can't say that but yes
I can a 19 year old is more attractive
than 26 year old woman and I'll tell you
why because that 26 year old has talked
to more guys been to the club more times
being effed and dumped more times more
arguments More Mess more for me to clean
up that is misogyny why because you are
encouraging a mindset about 25 year old
women that make some sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds you couldn't call that
misogyny you you would call it 25 year
old phobia or something anti-25 year old
rhetoric but it he's not attacking women
he's not criticizing women or insulting
women he's insulting 25 year olds and
it's on a faulty premise I think it's on
the premise of the sexual Revolution
that just women are going to be
promiscuous and that's inevitable and
it's true of all women so the issue he
has is not that a 25 year old is less
attractive than an 18 year old just by
the virtue of being 25 the premise
that's going into this is that the 25
year old has just slept with a bunch of
men which may very likely be the case in
our culture but it also may not be the
case because the 25 year old might be
chaste and modest and in fact it could
be the case that the 18 or 19 year old
has slept with more men than the 25 year
old so if that's really the issue that
that Andrew Tate is talking about then
the age is really just a kind of uh
shorthand for what he's saying which is
that he finds women who are less
promiscuous to be more attractive than
women who are more promiscuous and that
is broadly speaking true he's he's
suggesting that modesty is a greater
virtue for women than promiscuity which
is obviously true and Piers Morgan says
that this is misogynistic he's saying
it's somehow anti-woman to suggest that
women don't allow themselves to be used
for the physical pleasure of men who are
going to throw them in the trash the
minute that they're they're done with
them and they've had their pleasure but
that's quite the opposite it's actually
a very pro-woman to say hey ladies the
sexual Revolution is a total scam don't
let your yourself get used by men for
their sexual pleasure don't let the guy
get the milk for free instead of buying
the Cow Speaking of Andrew Tate's in
politic comments on property actually
Andrew Tate is giving much more
pro-woman advice here than Piers Morgan
seems to be doing Andrew Tate has this
quality that I think Alex Jones has Alex
Jones has this quality where he very
often says true things in the least
believable way possible so he'll say
something that's true he'll say like
like two plus two equals four but
instead of just saying two plus two
equals four he'll be ripping his shirt
off and you know screams like two plus
two equals four and if you don't believe
in that then you believe in the aliens
and the tricoms and whatever you know
and but what he's saying actually is
very often true and and Andrew Tate has
this issue here he's saying hey women
you should be more modest and not allow
yourself to be used by a bunch of dudes
that will actually in the long run make
you more attractive to men and more
attractive to better men but he somehow
manages to say it in the most vulgar and
grotesque and defensive way he possibly
can but the point is totally true well
firstly even if that was the case that
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more desired 25 year old woman
Auntie 25 year old women we can argue
but not misogynistic that's no no no
it's not being anti any woman at all is
misogyny not when I'm not what I'm
saying that women are beautiful and
attractive at a certain age and saying
the ages you're saying 18 lunches are
more attractive than 21 other than
ageist perhaps but misogynistic
absolutely but you just accepted it was
misogyny no I didn't you said it was
most Sergeant I'm telling you no it's
not so you don't think if you're saying
slightly hateful things about it
hateful well it is you say that to a
woman's face if she's 25 it's not
slightly hateful when you would go up to
25 year old woman and tell her exactly
what I've just read why would I walk up
to a random 25 because you said it in
public it's on the internet and it's
been listened to and watched by millions
and millions of young Impressions there
was a large panel there was a
conversation there was hours Longs of
conversation there were feminists
attacking men for toxic masculinity and
attacking me and saying things and I
said things back which we're going to
attack I think see I'm I so what you've
done yourself a bunch of times I think a
lot of allegations of toxic masculinity
are not toxic correct I do think that
kind of uh sentence I just read out that
that paragraph is actually toxic if you
genuinely mean it's toxic to say women
don't sleep around with a bunch of dudes
said it in public about a toxic
that's medicinal
you probably do too I don't think it's
misogynistic I understand why it can be
insulting too you wouldn't say it to a
woman's face I'd well it depends you're
making out like I'm walking around the
street going up to random 25 you're
doing it to tens of millions of people
online there's no difference not at all
no then it's no different so then he
would do it you hear a person where he
says you would never say that to a
woman's face Andrew Tate says why would
I walk up to a random woman and say that
and Pierce Morgan says well you do it
online there's no difference okay if
there's no difference then I guess he
would say it to a woman's face clearly
Piers Morgan is just offended that
Andrew Tate thinks that young women
shouldn't sleep around with random dudes
and why Piers Morgan is offended by this
I don't know but Andrew Tate here is
making the good wholesome pro-woman
argument and Piers Morgan wittingly or
unwillingly is leading those poor young
girls stray young boys right in their
teens are you comfortable that they
would have that mindset be honest I
think that young boys in their teens
lack life experience they lack nuance
and they need to be very very careful
what they're digesting online whether
it's my content or anybody else's I
think you know for a fact millions of
them are digesting exactly what you're
saying completely the entire internet to
a degree I think any any subject you can
find there's going to be a whole I come
back to the Joe Rogan thing Andrew is it
a lot of what you say I agree with yeah
right I do genuinely I've read a lot
I've written a lot of stuff you said a
lot of the stuff you talk about I think
he's got a good point right somebody
agree about a lot of things but when I
read that kind of thing I'm like I just
how much of that is you how much of that
is some ACT do you regret saying stuff
like this I don't actually do you see it
as weakness to admit you shouldn't have
said something like that no I don't live
with regret I think what's happened is
that like I said long format content
arguments with feminists arguments with
the toxic masculine crowd arguments with
the left and they're going to take a
small clip small sentence from hours and
I'm going to try and paint me and I'm
not left or right I don't know what you
are Pierce exactly that's my point
that's my point Pierce Morgan actually
does not cut totally evenly left or
right but we do know that he on social
issues is left-wing on the culture he's
very clearly left-wing he's just
admitted that right he's just said yeah
promiscuity is great and you know hyper
individualism and no Mutual obligations
to one another so he's obviously left
wing on that he's super left-wing on
guns he is pro-monarchy he's a Brit and
he's pro-monarchy so that's a kind of uh
you know conservative view though
doesn't really track in America because
we don't have a monarchy uh he doesn't
like certain Libs he kind of like Donald
Trump so yeah it's a little murky but on
these issues there's no question peers
is on the left and you're doing exactly
as I knew would happen on this interview
which is because you're a busy man
you're not going to watch hours and
hours and hours of video actually I
haven't watched thousand hours of video
and I'm going to come to the stuff where
I agree with you and I'm going to come
to the stuff about your censorship which
I have issues with so this is It's a
Long interview right sure I just thought
off the top you said to me and you were
quite bold about it well go on then
let's go through this and you and you
should keep going I will sit here and
stand by what I said I believe that oh
man on that I just read to you then yeah
do you wish you hadn't said that I
understand how it's been misconstrued I
understand how it's been weaponized and
used against me well that's slightly
annoying did I that's not why did I at
the time mean what I said and in the
context of the conversation which
obviously you you're not familiar with
and the people at home are not familiar
with no I meant what I said the 25 year
old women have just talked to more guys
been to the club more times been effed
and dumped more times more arguments
More Mess more for me to clean up well
there's a whole much there's a whole
bunch of context and conversation around
that that's been missed and I don't
think I'm missing much context well I I
encourage people who are interested to
go watch it right but I mean I've just
read out three sentences on the bounce
there I don't think there's any context
I'm missing this is but he says you're
missing all the context of the
conversations people's like three
sentences yeah exactly you don't get
context in three sentences I was
explaining I was talking with a Muslim
guy who was on the panel and he was
explaining how youth is very valid
valued in most parts of the world and
why Virginia is valued in both parts of
the world the feminists were arguing
against it and I was sitting there
actually very much like you a mediator
between the two explaining why and most
of the world still today perhaps not in
the Western World virginity is Coveted
youth is Coveted in most of the world
and per and throughout all of human
history and I was sitting there making
the point explaining why in certain
parts of the world they think how they
do well you know even though it's very
different to the Western World so I was
making a point mediating between two
groups very similar to yourself the
conversation has been misunderstood
they've taken this clip of it and it's
being weaponized and used against me I
understand that is because I'm now the
most famous Google person on the planet
it's inconvenient sure but I'm
definitely not a danger to women in any
regard I date women 25 26 27 years old
all the time none of them are offended
by the things I don't think you're a
danger to women I think that I think the
danger if it concerns you the danger is
the influence you have on young men to
have this kind of mindset about women
and that's really what I'm trying to get
to what you really believe and how much
you've just shot off because you think
it's like entertaining and you haven't
really given it much thought and whether
now you're a bit older and you've had
all the Fallout where the part of you is
thinking actually if I had as Joe Rogan
says if you hadn't said stuff like this
you'd probably still be on these
platforms you'd be massively more
popular massively more famous massively
richer so I'm really just trying to get
to on the blatantly misogynist stuff do
you just wish you hadn't said it with
great power comes great responsibility
it was certainly said before the great
power came it's inconvenient to a degree
however like I said at the time with the
context of the conversation I know that
I'm not saying things which I believe to
be detrimental to the world however
they've been misconstrued and they've
been misunderstood if a 25 year old
woman was watching this would you say
I'm sorry for saying that well I
wouldn't I don't want to be offended by
anything I say but I say things when I
say things that offend and this is the
thing that's interesting Pierce please
let me finish are you again you're
believing like a politician but hang on
you could say I'm interrupting you do
but you're answering a different
question
as an interview
sure okay you accept that that's except
we both got up okay so again my point is
simply if a 26 year old woman is
watching this and has heard those
comments see at this at this point it's
doing pretty well because he's kind of
mocking Pierce a little bit but at this
point it's really tedious for the viewer
too all peers are saying is
misogynistic and Tate says no it isn't
no it is it is no it isn't no it is no
it isn't so at that point you say well I
reject your premise peers I don't think
it's true and I think very clearly if my
criticism is of some women but not other
women and by the way even those two
groups of women are just stand-ins for
broader Concepts like modesty and
promiscuity even if let's say it's 25
year old woman versus 18 year old women
then by definition my criticism can't be
misogynistic because the Common Thread
between what I like and don't like is
women that's common to both the thing
that I'm criticizing here is age so call
me an ageist or something even though
again age is just a stand-in for broader
concepts of virtue your premise is wrong
so I reject that and then Pierce just
keeps saying take it back do you take it
back are you sorry do you take it back
and at this point because it's dragged
on so long I I just think Andrew Tate
has to realize this is not a good faith
conversation just say I don't I'm not
sorry but I used
I'm not but do you take it back no but
are you sorry no and at a certain point
if you just keep saying no no no no no
Pierce has to move on I will say that I
am sorry that that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
it doesn't mean you're sorry no I'm not
sorry that's the point I'm making I'm
sorry if that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
that believed that and I was mediating
for a conversation parts of the world
that believed that about 26 year old
women are parts of the world where women
are not allowed out on their own that's
your that's a conversation well that's a
conversation they're not allowed to
drive cars that's nothing to do with it
but is that the kind of world for a
woman I was mediating a conversation
I'll ask you what you think I don't live
in a country where that happens you're
using that as the excuse for why you're
not sorry for saying
just double down say I believe what I
believe move on it's fine I don't think
it's fine I live in a world where you
don't think it's fine my the reason this
isn't that hard Andrew you can simply
say beers you know what with the benefit
of hindsight don't say that I said it
like that no don't say that don't give
him what he wants I'm sorry I said that
because I'm not sorry I believe every
word I said and screw you appears that's
what you got to say parts of the world
it's not a view I share now I would
respect you more if you said that yeah
right because you're a big lib and you
want me to I think you want me to
encourage women to be promiscuous but
I'm not doing that I'm not sorry and
we're moving on my content existed
because I tried my very hardest to be an
absolute not a realist especially with
uncomfortable things I was pointing out
when you were explaining you're losing
on the optimal truth in many parts of
the world it's not a proof that I'm
happy about it's not true no hang on
you're digging it again what do you mean
that's a truth in other parts of the
world that's what you said it's not
you're not talking about another person
you're talking about what do you believe
modesty is 18 and 90 year olds and 20.
it's a fact about your belief I was
talking about what the people on the
panel believe the difference is yeah
stop trying to get out of it oh the
difference is age what's the difference
there well then 26 year olds older than
the 19 year old and so you stand by what
you said that's a dumb argument
after dump more times if the age is a
stand-in for for these Concepts and it's
a good argument if it's just the age
then it's a not a good I don't think
that the age is the only thing that's
going to decipher well how many men and
women there you go just say sorry that's
a better argument not believing what I'm
saying it's about you understanding that
there's large conversations going on I'm
just reading back stuff you've said I
know I'm asking you do you believe it I
believe that it's more likely a 26 year
olds had more Partners than a 19 year
old right you don't know that I don't
know that you don't know that you don't
know that at all that that is a dumb
thing to say if you're saying that's my
premise I'm using these as sort of 26
women we're it's not about we're
repeating ourselves here yeah and you're
both just not
you're you're just talking completely
past one another and Tate is totally
taking the bait here
all he had to say is
here's
I was using 18 and 19 year olds
as one concept
and 25 and 26 year olds is another
concept as it would be popularly
understood
to represent relative modesty and
inexperience and even perhaps virginity
and promiscuity it is a fact here there
everywhere around the world that modesty
and virtue and virginity are to be
preferred to promiscuity and allowing
men to use you for their sexual pleasure
until they throw you in the trash and
then some other guy picks you up
that is just a fact and it might offend
you because you think that women should
just go sleep around with any guy who
Winks at them and and but that won't
make them happy it won't lead them to a
good life it's not objectively good and
so we're having a moral disagreement
here peers and I'm on the side of
modesty and virtue and you're on the
side of sledding it up and I'm right and
you're wrong
he was sorry for I'm not sorry I just
explained you exactly what I said and
the way that I phrased it was was
metaphorical and I used some narrative
and I took some creative license but the
point that I I think pretty clearly made
was true and it remains true but do you
regret it I don't regret it it was true
but are you will you apologize
and it would have ended that misery of
of an interrogation
you believe depression is a real thing I
believe that feeling depressed is real I
don't believe depression as a clinical
disease is real no really correct you
don't believe people can be clearly
depressed I think PTSD is very real I've
unfortunately I have some friends who
suffer from that and I know that feeling
depressed is real I believe that the
number one power you have against these
things are taking trying to take control
of your own mind and affecting your own
life I believe that it's not healthy to
hand over all your power and believe
that depression is an outside disease
that you can't affect true I know that
when I've had difficult periods in my
life and also many of my friends like
I've said suffered from PTSD and been
through terrible things I've lived a
very difficult life and I know people
who have that the things that made them
feel better is when they woke up and
said you know what I'm not going to
allow this to damage me anymore I'm
going to take responsibility I'm going
to get up and I'm going to fight this as
hard by the way on that I agree my
favorite speech is the Rocky Balboa okay
so then we agree no we didn't we don't
agree Pierce you don't hang on you've
got to let me sure interject when I
don't agree with you right where I don't
agree with you is that there's no such
thing as clinical depression there
absolutely is well it's a proven
scientific medical reality there's a
different argument about have we gone a
bit too soft right in schools and all
the rest of it absolutely yeah do I
think some people moan and whine too
much about their lot in life definitely
okay are we a victimhood society 100
okay is there such a thing as clinical
depression absolutely so and my argument
is that if you actually bracket
everybody who's not guilty depressed and
doesn't have the genuine medical
condition then actually if millions of
people are deemed to have depression the
ones who really need the help don't get
it well that's my point well that can
that that I would agree with you're
right I think it's certainly overused
terms of things no I don't and that to
me is a damaging view okay Andrew Tate's
view is the more correct of these two
views
these guys are both wrong but Andrew
Tate's view is closer to being correct
Andrew Tate got most of his Soliloquy
correct except for that first part the
first part where he said you've just got
to take full responsibility of just your
own life you're the one in control
you've just you got to realize you're
the only one making decisions that's not
true that's not going to help you
because it's again it's a it's a world
view that that is missing God and so if
you're missing God then you're missing
the whole thing especially when we're
talking about matters of Despair what
does despair mean it means the lack of
Hope what is hope hope is a fact and a
theological virtue faith hope and
charity are the three theological
virtues and so without faith in God hope
is impossible at least at least in the
long run at least on the things that
matter the reason that they're both
wrong is because they're they're having
a debate about
depression as a physical
thing and depression as a metaphysical
thing depression obviously has a
physical aspect probably not a chemical
imbalance because that's been pretty
much debunked but but depression looks
like something you can't get out of bed
you're listless you're not you're not
hungry you kind of mope around and drag
your feet and maybe there are and maybe
there is a chemical quality to it in the
brain or some physical manifestation of
it in the brain or anywhere else it
certainly has that it also has a
metaphysical quality to it too you feel
your Melancholy you feel your spirits
are kind of down you're maybe thinking
of really sad and dark things maybe
you're even contemplating suicide at the
extreme of it and so that's not physical
that's metaphysical what these guys want
to do is cleanly and neatly separate it
one or the other but that's just so
modern nothing nothing now one thing on
this Earth is just physical
or just metaphysical not God himself
is just metaphysical because God himself
is Incarnate that's the Incarnation that
is Jesus Christ is the word the logos
the Divine logic of the universe made
flesh and dwelling Among Us in real time
and space and that is the understanding
of the relation between symbol and
symbolized that forms our entire culture
and led to all of the greatness of
Western Civilization led to our very
Consciousness right now and over time
especially as we've moved away from that
religion and that understanding of the
world those those Concepts have become
so abstracted that we're having these
incredibly stupid debates where where
everybody loses because both sides are
representing some part of the whole some
facet of the whole of reality but nobody
seems to be representing the fullness of
Truth and so it's just going to be
Babble back and forth and no one's going
to get to the heart of the matter I
would say the first thing you need to do
is stop accepting the identity of a
clinically depressed person stop
accepting you have no control over this
and what you need to do is stop
identifying that way and let's work
together to try and fight there isn't an
eminent doctor in the world who would
tell you there is no such thing as
clinical depression who would not tell
you that I think I think you're simply
Beyond I think Johann Hari wrote a book
saying exactly that my friend well Johan
Hari is a journalist sure and and my
point is that a lot of people who are
clinic so are you peers you're all
surgeon why am I taking your stupid word
that's not disease but Andrew not
situational Andrew You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in this is so shallow it
makes me want to pull my hair out I
can't become clinically depressed why do
you know because I don't believe in it
again this is that little area where you
lose me no I don't lose you somebody
with your following so thousands of
people the thousands of people who have
emailed me saying my doctor told me I
was clinically depressed and it's a
disease that I have got in my brain and
I can't be fixed and I started listening
to you and I realized that that's not
the case and I can fix my own life and
you're the only person who has never
helped me thousands of people have
emailed me yeah I bet I bet Andrew Tate
is more helpful than most psychiatrists
on this issue 100 depression you are
living in Cloud Cuckoo I am reading the
emails of people who I have cured of
clinical depression you're reading
emails from people who have believed you
when you say there isn't such a thing
and they've probably never been
diagnosed illegal depressed they just
want to go along with what Andrew dates
says I don't think so and I think your
view of that is that view is dangerous I
I respect that you think my view is
dangerous and I respect Pierce's
argument is so shallow I fear I'm going
to be sucked through the floor and
disappear forever into the abyss ptsds
are very real it's actually going to
become concave I did not not say
clinical depression is massively over
diagnosed I said that people who claim
to be depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words a lot of
people who just have a bad day and
declare I've got depression and I I say
well have you been to a doctor have you
been clinically diagnosed if you have
and you have clinical depression that's
one thing but if you haven't we could
probably work on some mental strength
and resilience skills with it but a
clinically depressed person has a an
absolutely proven medical condition that
is beyond their control not according to
me and many others my friend well look
what do you know about it honestly I
know I know what do you know I'm not a
doctor a psychiatrist you're none of
those things sure you're a guy on a
Psychiatry it's amazing that he's
referring to Psychiatry here because one
who's he really referring to some pop
doctors who have lost so much of their
credibility in recent years the entire
medical establishment during covet loss
so much of its credibility that the
lobbies you know I think of the American
Medical Association or the Psychiatric
association they changed the DSM the
guidebook of mental disorders based on
political correctness because it's no
longer politically correct to point out
that men who think that their women are
mentally ill they just change the
definition in the DSM based on what not
based on science or based on truth but
based on political correctness
furthermore psychiatrists in the throes
of a major crisis right now is the major
replication crisis which is a huge
number of major psychiatric studies
cannot be replicated they have
absolutely no scientific rigor to them
whatsoever and so the idea that peers is
deferring to these people as the be-all
and end-all Authority is totally
laughable it's not only the category
error here of pretending that that
depression is purely physical or purely
metaphysical just like that anything is
purely physical or purely metaphysical
but it's also just a a really basic
journalistic fact-checking error it's an
error of what authorities to trust
because he's deferring to people who
have a terrible track record on the
truth much of which I agree with as
you've seen in the interview but some of
which is ludicrous and that's one of
them it's not ludicrous it is it's not
you said to me we're in a victim whose
Society has got to stop and we're there
okay at the moment you try and deny
clinical depression I believe feeling
depressed is real I do not believe it's
a disease that you catch from the sky
and you cannot affect I believe that no
matter what happens I believe you have
control of your own mind and you can
fight against it I believe if you change
your circumstances in your life you may
feel different I'll give you a quick
example to a large degree that's true
but not in all cases I obviously am not
a psychiatrist I'm not a doctor I told
him because I reply to my emails I said
have you been to a psychiatrist he said
yes I'm clinically depressed I've been
on these pills this amount of time I've
not antidepressants it doesn't work I
said I don't know what to say to besides
this
and he said he lost his girlfriend
that's why I became clinically depressed
I said listen go to the gym get a
six-pack first once you've got a
six-pack email me again
still feel like killing yourself I don't
know what else to say to you but I'd say
strong body is a strong mind GO train
he went he started sending me progress
pictures emailing me him getting in
better better shape and eventually got
six-pack he's not a professional
bodybuilder and he said I can't believe
I was considering that I feel so much
better Etc the doctor was telling him he
was clinically depressed and couldn't
cure it he started taking control of his
own life and now he felt better now I'm
not saying it's the case for everybody
I'm just saying my question have you
seen the guy's medical records of course
not I just told you the student is
taking his word for it I am taking the
words of a man who emailed me with a
bunch of medication and specifics he was
denying proven science because one guy
writes to you who you help and you've
not seen any evidence you ever had
clinical depression diagnose I'm denying
the idea proven science go on your your
the overarching theory of clinical
depression
uh that is the basis for the the modern
psychiatric prescriptions on clinical
depression the idea of the chemical
imbalance theory that demands the
widespread use of these expensive
depression drugs that one in eight
Americans are now hooked on and one in
29 teenagers are now hooked on a
scientific basis for that just got
completely gutted and there is no
evidence whatsoever that ssris
correct any sort of chemical imbalance
that just within the last
what's five or six weeks that whole
thing has been gutted and and yet you
still hear from Piers Morgan it's the
proven science The Proven science ignore
the reality of the people that are
telling you actually what's happening to
them I don't know I'm going into a
little bit of a Paul McCartney all the
time well you know here Andrew Taylor
yes
so here's Morgan I'll just speak in the
American accent for now no I'll speak in
the Paul McCartney accent he says you
know so you're you're going to look at
all of your emails and you're going to
talk to all the people that you know and
they're going to show you the results
and you think that just because you've
seen it in reality that that's actually
better than what's been published in
these bogus medical journals is that
what you think and to entertain says
yeah or at least I hope he says yeah
because that's obviously much more
reliable than the BS statistics that
that have largely been debunked yeah
rants in public to tens of millions of
people denying something because this
guy writes to you and says he had it and
you cured him and I think that's a
dangerous mindset Andrew that's fine
that's why you don't have a responsible
view of your influence disagree it's
very responsible because I'm saving
people's lives I disagree that if you're
dying if you have if you feel depressed
I disagree that you cannot affect it and
change your life and take control and
fix yourself and feel happier I disagree
with you do you think do you think I
refuse to accept that there are people
out there who cannot become happy
contented individuals what is dangerous
about what he's saying is it gets back
to the same problem of a view that that
puts man at the center of the universe
rather than God at the center of the
universe because he's calling on men to
be their own saviors and and men cannot
be their own saviors you can do a lot to
help yourself you can do a lot to put
yourself in a better position you can
practice the virtues and make yourself
healthier to a large degree but you are
not ultimately in control of your
destiny or a fate or of the the order of
the universe ultimately God is and so
what's dangerous about this is that when
these things don't work and Andrew Tate
even admits that in some cases this
won't work you go to the gym and you
still will be a little bit depressed at
least for some group of people that you
blame yourself and it's the same problem
as the Prosperity Gospel this idea that
if you you know if you just pray a
little bit harder you'll get a lot more
money because God rewards people who
pray really hard by giving them a lot of
money so if you don't have material
success in this world that that must be
some kind of sign that you are not saved
or your faith is insufficient or
something and that that's very silly and
corrosive and really destructive he's
falling in some ways into the same air
appears morganis which is he's trying to
set the world up and establish a view of
the world on Purely phys physical
grounds you know he's trying it's just
not you just go to the gym and you just
lift the weights and you just get
combined mind over matter you know and
you and you pull you yourself will just
pull your body into into submission once
you have that six-pack you won't be
depressed anymore but that's not
necessarily true this is a fallen world
there's a lot of Brokenness there are a
lot of things that are unexplained a lot
of work around the fringes and
ultimately ultimately you are not in
control which is why you need to have
faith and hope and charity for your
fellow man I refuse to accept we live in
a world where God has created people who
no matter how hard they work and how
good their life becomes can't be happy I
don't accept that I accept that the
universe is a very giving place and that
God loves all of us and if you try your
best and you work hard you can become a
better person and I also will argue with
you and I'll counter yes you can become
a better person you're a platform
telling people they have clinical
depression there's nothing they can do
about it it's far more data okay well
then if they have clinics why do you
misquote no because you're saying being
misquotes no you're saying if people
have clinical depression about it they
go to a doctor and they get diagnosed
I would argue the point that if somebody
has depression of any kind whether it's
clinical whether it exists or not
whether they feel depressed or not
whatever that taking control of their
life taking personal responsibility and
working hard is always going to be the
positive best thing they can possibly do
for their life going forward
so sitting there saying I don't believe
in clinical depression you don't believe
in depression no I don't I believe that
people can take control and fight
against things I believe in personal
sovereignty right right that's the
problem good so we agree they'll be done
yes we do no be done fears are on my
side you're afraid of being canceled
along with me I said to you from the
start that's all I agree with a lot of
what you say completely so I thought I'm
taking you to task over the stuff I
don't agree he's saying ultimately I I
believe in in personal sovereignty right
and I like people exercising their own
will and having some control over their
lives in its proper place but but I
don't agree with Andrew Tate here I do
not believe ultimately is the be all and
end-all first principle in personal
sovereignty that is what this serpent in
the Garden of Eden told to Eve okay that
is what the satanists of the 20th
century insisted upon the first
commandment of Aleister Crowley do
without Wilt I no no that's the bad
stuff I don't believe ultimately in the
the total personal sovereignty I believe
in the sovereignty of God and what's
good and he even is alluding to this and
he's even mentioning God but it doesn't
jibe with with so much of his worldview
it's quite incoherent when you accept
the sovereignty of God which really
establishes whatever good version of
individualism there is that comes by
acknowledging the sovereignty of God
which gives you so much more control
over your life the sort of thing he's
calling for and gives you true freedom
but if you reject that and you put man
as God you will be lost you will
ultimately not save yourself if you put
God at the center of the universe
then you will have tools to work through
sadness if you put man at the center of
the universe sadness becomes a sin and
being sad is not a sin sometimes things
are sad I was at a funeral recently it's
sad to be at funerals you don't want to
be sad all the time but grieving is fine
sorrow is part of human nature Jesus
wept shortest line in the gospel that
happens and and so the the fear of this
idolatry of man and of your own will and
and the sovereignty of the individual or
whatever is that ultimately when you are
sad because it's a Fallen World you
won't be able to make sense of that and
you won't be able to you all at a
certain point you won't be able to pull
yourself out of it go to missing in
maine.com use promo code Knowles I
absolutely adore missing in Maine for a
couple of reasons one I consider myself
an aesthet okay I really like good clean
style especially in men's clothing
missing in Maine cannot be beat but also
because I derive from the Italian
Peoples we perspire a little bit we're
not you know a lot of people perspire
and the missing and Main dress shirts
are so amazing because they're they're
like athletic wear in the way that
you're not going to sweat through them
but they look with have they have the
exact same style and crisp clean look of
dress clothing not just the Oxford
Insurance incredible performance polos
the they've got great chinos lightweight
breathable moisture wicking
absolutely phenomenal stuff if you want
the best dress shirts money can buy you
got to go to Missin and Maine that is
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code Knolls you will get 35 off any
regular price order of 125 or more 35
bucks off any regular price order of 125
bucks or more at Mison and main.com
promo code Knowles
let me tell you about Alex Jones right
he'll have a bit of history with each
other to get me deported from the United
States did he yeah what is your view of
Alex Jones I think that Alex Jones is a
sovereign individual who very much like
the Rabid left deserves a chance to
speak the people who insist on the
ultimate sovereignty of the individual
are the Rabid left or at least they
share the same premises as the radical
left it's funny that Andrew Tate is
called a right winger or a conservative
or something but so many of his he
shares exactly the same premises of the
left which is that the individual is
ultimately totally Sovereign consent is
ultimately the only thing that really
matters and you have no moral
obligations to anything higher than that
that's the leftist view that is that is
essentially what defines the left and so
it's just liberals arguing with liberals
you can tell he's got an intuition that
that's not sufficient which is why he'll
talk about God and he'll talk about
marriage and he'll talk about loyalty
and he'll talk about tradition but he
does it in this incoherent way because
when he makes moral statements he keeps
coming down to the same stupid leftism
that he that he criticizes truth on
issues is usually somewhere in the
middle between two extremes and I think
do you think Sandy Hook was staged I
don't know anything about Sandy Hook
really you know he's just been sued by
the families for millions and millions I
have no idea you done anything about it
no so why would you support someone in
public you know nothing about the most
infamous when have I supported him in
public you have supported him in public
I've been on this podcast yeah but you
said nice things about it I say nice
things about lots of people what do you
think about exchange I said nice things
about you pierce that's fine
so to sit and say that I've been on a
podcast and I say nice things about it
you said you support you support his
right to speak about things like Sandy
Hook I don't know Sandy Hook I don't
know you know what it was it was a mass
shooting of school children okay but to
sit and and he's actually no no let's
stop for a second please don't interrupt
me I know why you're good at your job
first you interrupt people a lot which
is good it's a good skill and then there
you go prove me right but here's the
timing is good here's exactly what I do
I only interrupt people like you when
you either refuse to answer the question
or answer a completely different one
sure and I want to remind you of what
the question was when you misquote me
back which you've done repeatedly
through the interview where you say you
see peers you agree with me and the
viewer who's been watching me go no he
didn't cool no problem the other thing
you do is you try and set these traps
like now so you're saying what's the
Trap you think I'm sitting you're saying
that I agree with every single point of
view a man has I literally didn't say
that you're saying well you support Alex
Jones why did you misquote me because
you're saying you support Alex Jones and
you said he you've been on his podcast
and he said this I don't know what do
you think about exchange I don't know
everything he said what do you think of
him I think I think on his podcast he
was cordial I think he was professional
on his podcast I've also done podcasts
with rabid leftists and and people who
openly hate me is it wrong I do a
podcast circuit so I don't know
everything he's ever said when somebody
I don't know what so I don't know what
you're trying to get here because I
didn't get a word it's pretty it's a
it's a lame trick if you let me get a
word in I will tell you let's go Tate is
totally right to call him out for this
Tate's argument on Alex Jones could be
listen as Alex Jones said some things
that are really outlandish yeah of
course he has has he said things that
are really awful and terrible I don't
really listen to Alex Jones but sure
probably he has I've said things that
are awful and you've said things that
are awful so I'm sure Alex Jones has two
has Alex Jones gotten major stories
wrong yeah probably you know what I'll
tell you though Alex Jones if you go
Story by story if you just say here are
a hundred stories that Alex Jones
covered in 100 stories that CNN covered
I would bet you a lot of money that Alex
Jones has a better track record than CNN
and so if Piers Morgan is insisting that
you know we just focus on one this one
story or this one statement or this one
Whatever from this one guy and we have
to disavow me it's just a silly game and
that that's what Andrew Tate is pointing
out there and so he's absolutely right
about that I just wish
the guy clearly has good
a good gut instinct he realizes
something is wrong with the culture that
we're in right now he's articulating his
problem with what's wrong right now
in a clumsy way which is probably why
he's gotten so popular actually is I
think if he had said it in a more
articulate and precise way no one would
have paid as much attention so it's
probably benefited him in terms of his
notoriety but I I also wish that he
would take it even further he's got his
intuitions about this he's right he's
got the kind of scheme of what's gone
wrong in the world he's he realizes some
something's up but at the at that bottom
philosophical and Theological level he
hasn't quite worked out why it's wrong
and so he can't quite articulate it
which is why he can fill it fall into
the traps that Piers Morgan laid for him
and does not totally successfully dig
out of them just got to go all the way
down to First principles figure it out
maybe we should have him on the show
it'd be great to have him on the show
until then I'm Michael Knowles see you
next time